45 people were killed by Russian air strikes...
...on a rebel-held area of northwestern Syria.
Slovenia accuses Croatia of sending migrants to the country without control...
...and urges the rest of the EU to get involved in solving the crisis.
In Germany, thousands gather for an anti-migrant rally...
...marking the one-year anniversary of PEGIDA...
...and highlighting the backlash against the influx of migrants.
Justin Trudeau and the Liberal Party pull off a stunning victory...
...in Canada's parliamentary election.
And finally from the United Kingdom, Chinese President Xi Jinping...
...was welcomed by the Royal Family on his four-day state visit...
...aimed at cementing economic ties.